Hey YouTubers it's Charlie. So this is gonna be
my Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.  episode seventeen video.
Since there's a whole bunch of Avengers news
and stuff going on around the premiere
and phase three I'm gonna try and work that
in too, so the video will be just
a little bit different from my normal format.
What I'll do is just talk about each of the big
running plot lines and then I'll move into
related Marvel Avengers stuff. So here we
go. Careful for spoilers in case you haven't
seen the episode yet.
Starting with Coulson's secret army. I
think is pretty clear here that Coulson
has been building
infrastructure for new Inhuman people
that he expects to find.
The reason I think the real S.H.I.E.L.D.  wants
to get their hands on the tool box
is because it has information on
where all these people are that Coulson has
targeted and where all his bases are.
Just to take it a step further, I
really do think that they're trying to track
down the people
the real S.H.I.E.L.D. are trying to find the
super-powered people. Yeah it's a big deal that Coulson
is stockpiling supplies and weapons
but I think the real S.H.I.E.L.D.  is more
worried about the inhumans than they
are about the bases themselves.
What i think is going to happen is
that during Age of Ultron we'll get a
little more context
as for why all these bases are necessary. They'll do most of the explaining on Agents
of S.H.I.E.L.D. like throughout the rest the season.
We'll find out exactly what Coulson is
doing. I think Age of Ultron
in the movie will add some context to that so
it'll make a little more sense
especially giving us Nick Fury's
perspective on the whole thing.
They are building out so that you don't
have to go see the movie to understand
what's going on in Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
and vice versa but they do kinda work
together to create a little more context.
I also think all of this Coulson's secret inhumans base Deathlok technology stuff
is gonna tie in with the spinoff show.
They said that the remaining
episodes this season will set up what's
happening in the spinoff show so
it'll all make sense by the time we get
to the end of the season.
As you probably guessed from the
end teaser too Fitz will totally join up
with Coulson. He'll totally shake the tail.
I love the way Hunter teased this big
WTF moment that we never saw.
"Is there a dryer in that bathroom? yes?
You're gonna be okay mate."
Sometimes those are the best moments; the
ones that you don't see.
Like your brain just
imagines something crazy happening.
Jumping over to the inhuman. Skye
finally meet her mother and plays with her
powers a little bit.
I said it before I think this
real S.H.I.E.L.D. vs. S.H.I.E.L.D. stuff will figure into
Captain America: Civil War.
It seems like they're teasing a civil
war inside the inhuman's society too.
Skye's mother explains that there are very
strict rules
and how people would get really pissed
if they found out the Jiaying was Skye's mother.
She's the one that created the
rules about who gets to take in the
Terrigen Mist.
They did a really good job of tying that to the Agent May plot. The family dinner also very
touching.
I think Skye was being genuine. She was
happy to have dinner with her mother and
father even though she still hates her
father.
There was a small easter egg for
Daredevil in here because
it seems like Skye and Daredevil stayed at
the same orphanage for a period of time.
although Daredevil is a little bit older.
Skye said she's twenty six.
They made it a big deal to say what her birthday
was which was kinda funny. Matt Murdock in
the timeline right now, and I think
Daredevil and Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. are running
concurrently right now like relatively
in the same time frame. He's closer to
like twenty-eight/twenty-nine so he's a little bit older.
They could have been at the orphanage at
the same time.
I know there's always a big question
like "what things get to cross over with
other things". I think the ABC shows and the
Netflix shows have high potential for
cross over. It's much easier
than say crossing Daredevil over with
the movies. Lincoln showing up at the end
with a lot of fun too
because he realized that Raina is clairvoyant
which is a nice twist on Garrett
in season one.
She kept talking about the clairvoyant.
Surprise surprise she turned out to be
clairvoyant in real life.
Like a real clairvoyant not just someone
stealing secrets. They're still trying to
figure out where Raina's powers are so I
think it'll go beyond clairvoyance. It
won't just be that.
She'll probably have some sort of physical
ability too with her spikes. George R.R.
Martin said this really interesting
thing
about the way you build out
super-powered characters. He said you have
to balance stats otherwise it becomes
completely ridiculous.
He was talking about board games like role playing board games.
So if a character is really big and
really strong they're probably not very
dexterous. They probably don't have
very strong magical resistance abilities.
If a character is like a dwarf with a lot
of physical deformities and can't move
really fast
he probably has very strong magic. So by
that logic
Raina being extremely disfigured
probably has
very powerful abilities. I'm interested
to see if there is some sort of civil
war that's going on inside the
inhuman society and it positions Raina and Gordon on one side
and Lincoln, Skye, and her mother on
another side.
It seems like Lincoln is a pretty
nice guy. I don't think he's gonna sell
Skye out.
It's unclear as to whether or not he
knows Jiaying is Skye's mother.
It seems like he doesn't. Based on the
way that the show has
presented him it seems like they want us
to think of him as a friend
as opposed to Gordon who is a little more
neutral. It seems like he favors Raina
but he's gonna be taking care of her
emotionally and taking care of her training.
So if Raina hates Skye it would stand to reason
that Gordon would support Raina
over Skye. We'll see how that develops
because it seems like the Inhumans
afterlife place is just like a hornet's
nest waiting to explode.
So jumping to the Agent May plot line we
find out all about her past; why it is
she has such crazy PTSD.
She killed a child. Admittedly a crazy
powerful child that she had to kill
but it was so much fun seeing her so
decompressed like seeing the mundane
Agent May.
She was still very powerful. Still a badass
fighter but she didn't have that edge
that she has in the present-day scenes
If you were a little confused as to what
was going on: the mother
was an Inhuman who had a daughter, who
wanted her daughter to be able to take
in the Terrigen Mist
as her birthright. Jiaying, Skye's mother,
detected a darkness quote-unquote.
Detected that the child was crazy so she
was like "nope".
So she wanted to prevent that. So the
mother ran away with the child, stole
some Terrigen crystals,
and the child got crazy psionic
abilities. You could think of it as a
reference to Maximus
the Mad who is Black Bolt's crazy brother
and has mad psionic abilities.
We do get to see like the endpoint like
she ends up at the desk where we see
her at the beginning at season one.
So is was a nice way to tie it back to the
beginning. Here's my big question for you guys:
What was your favorite moment
from the episode, and are there any other
characters on the show
who we haven't seen a flashback for that
you really wanna see one?
The other really tortured person we saw a flashback for was Ward.
We learned all about his crazy family. I
think he's actually back next week so be
sure to subscribe to get that video. It's
gonna be a lot of fun
I really like the direction that Ward's
character has taken. He is so much more fun
than he was in season one.
So moving into Avengers phase three
stuff. There's a whole bunch of stuff that's
been said because
Age of Ultron is coming out. They're doing press
conferences so I'm gonna start with the
Hulk movie.
Mark Ruffalo just explain why there is
no Hulk movie on the books right now.
Marvel wants to do one. They will do one
eventually. It's just matter time.
He said that Universal technically still
has the legal rights.
That's why Marvel hasn't attempted one
so far. Side note
Joss Whedon also wanted to make Avengers
2 much more about the Hulk
and Hawkeye so he asked the other phase two directors
to not feature those characters.
Just because he was gonna spend so much time on
them. So it's just a matter time
till marvel get the rights back and they
can actually do a solo Hulk
film. By that time Mark Ruffalo
might have completed his contract so
unless he re-ups and does more Hulk
films after his contract is up, his
six picture contract,
we might see another actor in a solo
Hulk film.
The actors that are closest to
completing their contracts are
Chris Hemsworth
and Chris Evans. They have three
pictures each left
and they're already on the books. It's like
their next solo film, and then the two
Avengers films.
What I'm expecting is that of the
original Avengers class, like the
original actors to play these big
Avengers characters,
most to them will resign their contracts
but one or two of them will probably
leave.
You have to remember that right now
we have seven, eight, nine Avenger
characters. That's a lot so they're
not
all gonna stick around forever. Speaking
of new Avengers there
are details on the Spider-Man character.
Kevin Feige he was going on and on about
Spider-Man
and Captain Marvel. Feige was really nice
and he talked about like the role of the
Inhumans on the TV show
versus the Inhumans in the movies. What
he said is that
based on the budgets and the things that
you can do on TV
you could pretty much guess what we're
not gonna see on the TV show.
Mainly the royal family in Attilan.
Outside of that they'll completely
explore Inhuman society like the inner
workings of that.
Set things up so that there's a context
whenever the solo movie comes and we see
all the big spectacle stuff.
As for Spider-Man I think everybody
knows at this point they we're going to
be seen like a super young version of
him.
The costume itself will be much more
primitive.
He said that in the time line of the
movies right now there is
a little kid Spider-Man, like a high
school spider-man, swinging around
New York City
that people just don't know about yet.
When I say people I mean characters like
Matt Murdock
Tony Stark like the people inside the
Marvel Universe. The characters.
What they're gonna do is focused much
more on the classic wit
of the Peter Parker character much more so
than the other films have ever done. The other
Spider-Man films.
So this will be the funniest, most
wisecrackingly awesome Spider-Man
you've ever seen before
going forward. Chris Evans went on to say
that he really wants Captain America
to be a mentor to this young Spider-Man
character when we get to Captain
America: Civil War.
He will be in the movies. Spider-Man is
gonna be in civil war. We just don't know
how much.
We also know some stuff about
Captain Marvel. Originally she was
supposed to have a cameo in Avengers 2
but they just cut her out for practical
reasons.
Kevin Feige just said that they knew
they were going to do Captain Marvel
solo film
and they already had so many characters
in Avengers 2 that they were just like
"okay let's simplify this a little bit so
it doesn't get too crazy".
So they actually shot around planned
cameos
for her like they were gonna CG her
in the background.
Its just amazing how much you can change a
movie after you've already shot it.
They do have a writer, Nicole Perlman, who
is the one who initially developed
the Guardians of the Galaxy movie before
James Gunn came on and did his version
of the script.
She's gonna be writing Captain Marvel
with another person. Just as a reminder
Batman vs. Superman teaser is
supposed to drop tomorrow. I'll
totally do a video for it, and there's
supposed to be a new Star Wars: The
Force Awakens trailer. Star Wars Episode seven.
After I get through all that stuff there will
totally be new Daredevil so
hopefully new Daredevil by like Friday
or Saturday. While you guys wait for all that stuff
you can click here for the latest
Ant-Man trailer and you can click here
for last night's episode of The Flash.
Thank you so much watching. Everybody lets high five. I'll see you guys tonight.